[Music]
Tracy
how do you think it was like working
with Keanu Reeves he's like the sexiest
guy in the world we're both in our 20s
we're both single we're both gorgeous
but both in Hawaii come on give me a
break what do you think it was like it
was heaven and I would love to work with
him again anytime 24/7 call me up Keanu
we never close you got the digits homey
that's it Tracey come on Lori
thank you that's thank you for the
compliment I loved that movie too very
much the scariest moment was Patrick and
Keanu and I were out in Hawaii surfing
and we were out past the break and we
were just talking and they were on the
the sand and they had close-up blends of
super zoom lenses so they were shooting
us like this but we were really far away
so they didn't see this set wave coming
in that was literally 30 feet high and
we are you know actors not surfers so
this set wave comes in it's dark but
they don't even notice because they can
only see this so the set wave comes and
I figured we were all gonna die but we
had some bodyguards out there who were
from Hawaii and they said lay down lay
down on your board so I laid down he
lays on top of me pushes me down to the
bottom of the ocean we were down there
for you know an hour and a half and then
we grew back up and we couldn't find
Keanu seriously like nobody saved him
Keanu comes straggling up the beach like
yeah he was in you know Gilligan's
Island and he lived we all lived I got
ten stitches in my foot but that was the
scariest oh and the silly boys jumping
out of the plane I'm not doing that
that's their crazy they all jumped every
morning I just they said oh you're a
[ __ ] I'm like yeah
so that was the scariest yeah
[Music]
writing and directing my first film
which is the poker house which I wrote
and directed and Jennifer Lawrence plays
me in the booby and it was her first
film and that was my favorite Chloe
Moretz is in its imma Blair's in that
daily hunger is in it and you can get
the poker house on demand on Netflix
[Music]
Shelley it's all fun we wouldn't do it
if it wasn't fun so preparing for a role
is equally as fun as as between action
cut preparing is the joy of learning and
reading and creating and painting and
talking and rehearsing and all it's fun
it's all fun there's nothing difficult
it's just a joy it's a gift and a
pleasure to be able to do it
[Music]
I know way too much about myself Tatyana
there's nothing more no we don't need to
know anything more about me what's great
about acting is that you learn about
other people and so I get to learn more
about the world and the more about
others men and children and other
countries and languages it's not about
learning about myself it's about
learning it's about learning about
everyone in our interconnectedness and
how we're all one thing and that's the
reason you like movies because you can
watch a movie that you have nothing in
common with these people but you have
everything in common with these people
because that whole oneness thing
thank you very much Facebook
[Music]